Barack and I were both raised by
families who didn't have much in the way
money or material possessions but who
had given us something far more valuable
their unconditional love their
unflinching sacrifice and the chance to
go places they had never imagined for
themselves my father was a pump operator
at the city water plant and he was
diagnosed with multiple sclerosis when
my brother and I were young and even as
a kid
I knew there were plenty of days when he
was in pain and I knew there were plenty
of mornings when it was a struggle for
him to simply get out of bed but every
morning I watched my father wake up with
a smile now grab his Walker propped
himself up against the bathroom sink and
slowly shave and button his uniform and
when he returned home after a long day's
work my brother and I would would stand
at the top of the stairs of our little
apartment patiently waiting to greet him
watching has he reached down to lift one
leg and then the other to slowly climb
his way into our arms but despite these
challenges my dad hardly ever missed a
day of work he and my mom were
determined to give me and my
the kind of education they could only
dream up you got to be open to taking
some risks and not being afraid to fail
failure is the key to success so when
you get to college you got to raise your
hand you have to be engaged
don't be the kid thinking oh I shouldn't
be here and maybe I'm not smart enough
and maybe you know no you are more than
capable of being successful and going on
and doing whatever you want in life
I sit here because I am you all there is
no difference between me and you
working-class kid growing up on the
south side of Chicago growing up with
doubts and fears just like all of you
all do I know exactly how you all are
feeling and kids out there who were
thinking maybe I'm not ready maybe I'm
not good enough maybe I can't afford it
but what teachers and mentors have told
me is that yes you can and you must so
get in there and be bold with your
intelligence raise your hand get support
when you need it and know that we all
got here because somebody helped us you
just watched two amazing clips of
Michelle Obama take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]